[Musique]
et puis gâteaux biscuits riz des
maladies de sang au cancer c'est le
temps d'écrire aux ide ou les maladies
rhumatologiques tels que ceux de ses
enfants était trop difficile
elle était la ligne revivre et
maintenant vous voyez que le guet
télécom
comme tous les enfants elle se sent bien
pendant trois semaines ses enfants
biélorusses tous touchés par le nuage de
tchernobyl ont vécu en france en ville
nouvelle pour la plupart entre
hébergement dans des familles est sorti
c'est une expérience souvent unique pour
ces enfants de milieu modeste aux
situations familiales parfois difficile
une façon d'échapper à une vie où la
catastrophe nucléaire laisse encore des
traces même si comme le dit rina on n'en
parle plus trop génial quand cela fait
dix ans pour échanger nous n'aime pas en
parler et non parle pas vraiment cela
reste pourtant un vrai problème
notre gouvernement n'aide pas le secteur
humanitaire si on est venu et plusieurs
autres groupes à l'étranger c'est que
les gens de france par exemple nous aide
c'est pour cela que nous sommes ici six
enfants vivent
vivent leurs trois semaines ici un peu
comme un conte de feuilles c'est une
parenthèse dans leur vie et pour
certains
on essaie de leur expliquer aussi que
même s'il ya tout dans les magasins on
peut pas forcément tous leur acheter on
a de plus en plus de raison d'être parce
qu'en fait les conséquences médicales de
tchernobyl
quand voit que le
le bout de l'île de liesberg les
les semis sont en augmentation le retour
à la maison
l'amour
[Musique]
derrière ce terme anglais un peu barbare
se cache une technologie inédite qui
devrait permettre à 99 5 % de la
population yvelinoise de recevoir
l'internet à haut débit
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a choisi les deux
communes de montigny-le-bretonneux et de
lévis un nom parce qu'il ya une demande
très forte et tout à fait légitime de
ces deux communes pour avoir un une
éligibilité total de 100 % donc à l'adsl
parmi les autres innovations de france
télécom présentait ce matin ma ligne
visio également testé dans notre
département le mois dernier ce service
est aujourd'hui accessible à 84 % des
foyers yvelinois enfin le lancement
grâce à un partenariat avec tps de ma
ligne tv en juin dernier semble
satisfaisant 1500 abonnés sont recensés
dans les yvelines et la progression
annoncée de 250 clients par semaine
malgré l'obligation d'utiliser wanadoo
pour sa connexion internet ce mode de
réception de la télé numérique par la
prise téléphonique semble séduire avant
accessible à montigny voisin saint cyr
et guyancourt
elle vient d'ailleurs d'être étendu à
l'ensemble de la ville nouvelle reste
tout de même à savoir si l'offre ne crée
pas la demande
on voit bien qu'il ya un appétit très
fort des nouvelles technologies sur ce
département est donc au travail a amené
l'offre qui correspond justement assez
ambitieux d'innovation
[Musique]